hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
torten welt heute gibt es mal wieder ein
ganz schnelles rezept und ein ganz
einfaches und zwar mache ich heute
brownies modelle brownies und im prinzip
bestehen die nur aus drei zutaten
nämlich nutella eier und mehl aber ich
nehme gleich noch zwei zutaten um das
ganze noch ein bisschen aufzupeppen
das ist als auch wieder ein rezept was
ihr aus dem vorratsschrank einfach
machen könnt wenn ihr so irgendwie
schokoladen gelöste habt und einfach
lust auf so einen richtig saftigen braun
und ich zeige euch mal vor
als ich habe hier nutella 230 gramm 300
gramm mehl und es sind im prinzip die
grundzutaten die ihr braucht ich gebe
aber halt noch 50 gramm schoko drops mit
rein und 50 gramm haselnüsse und ich
packe es dann gleich hier in meiner
backformen der eckigen das habe ich
jetzt auf die kleinste größe eingestellt
müssten so 20 x 25 cm etwas sein und
jetzt gebe ich einfach alle zutaten hier
rein und verrisse miteinander einfach
alle zusammen können wir jetzt auch ein
handrührgerät mache mit einem
schneebesen schlüssel zu anstrengend
weil dies ist nutella halt so bisserl
zähflüssig ist einfach alles da rein
es ist ein rezept für die samira dies
nämlich das totale modelle liebhaber und
bei oma darf sie am wochen thema nutella
frühstücken
das führe ich hier jetzt gut
und nutzt die zeit schon mal um die hase
ein bisschen an zu rüsten
weil ich finde dann bekommen ist einfach
ein besseres aroma einfach ohne fett in
die pfanne geben und die pfanne heiß
werden lassen
und jetzt sind die nüsse angepasst hatte
sieht man auch daran dass die schale
also diese kleine haut so bittel
abplatzt und die nehme ich jetzt auch
ein bisschen weg und dann hab ich's
einfach mit einem messer zu klein
wenn es euch so zu heißen müsste halt
kurz warte aber
und jetzt gebe ich die schoko stücke mit
zum teig und hebt die einmal ganz kurz
unter dann auch ein paar nüsse und hab
ich nicht auf die gebe ich dann
obendrauf und der teig kommt dann direkt
in die backform rhein könnte man
normalerweise auch in einer springform
machen ist halt nicht rund er nicht so
einen hund ich im prinzip egal dann
schön drin verteile
und dann gebe ich da noch viel gehackte
nüsse mit drauf die restlichen und so
werden die brownies dann im vorgeheizten
backofen bei 180 grad ober und
unterhitze für ungefähr zwölf bis 15
minuten gebacken
die stäbchen probe mache ich in dem fall
dann nett weil die dürfen ja ihnen noch
so ein bisschen feucht sein
also damit dürfte da nicht danach gehen
weil wenn sie zu lange drin sind sind
sie trocken und es wolle man jetzt mag
ich die kurz und zeigt euch dann gleich
meine brown ist abgekühlt und der murat
darf jetzt auch gleich probieren und ich
bin selber schon gespannt denn ich habe
jetzt auch zum ersten mal gemacht als
auch wenn sie das perfekte braun ihre
teppich ich denke das ist ein cooles
rezept müssten wir schon mal gemacht ich
muss probieren
deswegen musste es probieren
so also die baulich sind ziemlich flach
weil es war ja auch relativ wenig wasser
und jetzt guck mal ich mag seinen raum
ist so richtig saftig sind ich auch
deswegen bin ich gespannt
ja stimmt den schoko überzug habe ich
jetzt nett gemacht den will ich dann bei
meinem anderen brown jetzt zu machen
mich so richtige richtige bronze freuen
ich befürchte nur dass ich sie
vielleicht seien zu lang gebacken habt
wobei ich sie zwölf minuten gebacken hat
ja es ist schon fast durchaus aber das
darf jetzt einfach mal probieren
das nicht ein teil
ich weiß nur dass ich mache das auch
schön
noch so ein text geschlagene sahne und
eine erdbeere morath es sich für dich
also wenn danny thönes beschädigt sieht
fast so aus wie auf meiner schulter
brownie ruhig ehrlich mal ganz ehrlich
widerlich kann ich nicht gut sagt ich
mich super
ich fand jetzt ein toller sommer schöner
wie den hebel
echt cool wird schön es freut mich also
auf jeden fall will sich halt der rat
findet gute sich auf jeden fall ein
rezept was man machen kann wenn man
einfach nächste heim hat auf wandteller
meloni und wenn man das ganze richtig
schnell machen will
vor allem ist es auch ein rezept was
auch kinder nachmachen können im prinzip
könnten nämlich einfach ein
handrührgerät benutzen und die masse
schnell zusammenrühren ihr müsst gar
nichts beachten keine reihenfolge und
eigentlich müssten die immer gelingen
die backzeit so zwischen zehn und 15
minuten
je nachdem was für eine form ihr habt
scheint geschmeckt zu haben dass heller
ist und ja wenn es nach machen wollte
ich schreibe ich trotzdem das rezept aus
- blog.de und da können uns gerne
nachmachen
auf jeden fall müsst ihr mir ein foto
auf facebook oder instagram schicken
dann würde ich mich echt darüber freuen
einfach mich markieren und ich sehe dass
dann auch und ja viel spaß dabei und wir
sehen uns beim nächsten mal
bis dahin tschüss muss auch probieren